and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn I am Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist welcome to episode 145 today
we're gonna talk about challenges
challenges are you challenging me not
that kind of challenge oh I get down
this whole cup of coffee right now you
can arm wrestle in the middle of this
podcast while downing a cup of coffee oh
you so we just did for the first time
Ryan has some follow up we just did a
pre-roll episode on YouTube yes we've
got good old Jordan Moore here the the
new video guy the new film maker on the
minimalist team and we and in him and
podcast Sean did on YouTube we're
starting to once a week on Tuesdays
although recording this on a Thursday
because Sean Jordan were both out of
town on in their respective cities with
families and so forth and so if you want
to check that out we basically do like
the show prep now on on YouTube five or
ten minutes we may end up answering some
questions we may talk about the
equipment that we're using for our
podcast and and what cameras were using
and what razor Jordan uses to shave his
head all of this will be revealed in
time but Ryan so so you and I were
having this this conversation last week
as I wrote it down here I think that's
why you're laughing yeah I'm just like
I'm looking at don't say anything okay
all right I'll say it after the fact
okay why I can't stop smiling and
laughing yeah so so we were sitting down
having this this conversation cuz you
were going through a challenge rather
coincidentally and if you want to talk
about that we could talk about that but
one of the things that helps me and
we're talking about challenges often
talking about perspective and there were
these four scenarios that we just sort
of came up with on the spot but but
there are things that really resonated
with me especially cuz I've gone through
a lot of hard times with my health the
last two years yeah and hopefully we go
there's time later on I'll give a health
update during the the right here right
now segments in fact let me write that
down so I remember cool
while you're writing that down I will
say the reason why these we the Josh and
I were talking about these perspectives
was because yes I was having a challenge
so I went to you and I'm like dude I'm
having this challenge like what what can
I do to kind of overcome this challenge
and yeah you started talking about
perspectives and how yes looking at
looking at your life and and really
understanding how the life that we live
it's pretty awesome compared to a lot of
other people's situations and
circumstances we're very fortunate yes
and absolutely we we're gonna continue
to have problems of course you want
problems because without without those
problems you're not gonna continue to
grow the the ideal thing is like my
problems at age 37 are thankfully better
than my problems at age 27 yeah and
which were better than my problems at
age 17 and so you and I grew up really
poor that that that presents a
particular set of financial problems but
also instability problems with respect
to our parents or our families and drug
abuse and alcohol abuse those are just
really bad problems and then you and I
had the corporate problems throughout
our 20s right yeah we we had these
problems if I'm working too many hours I
mean what what a privilege it is to be
able to work too many hours right but it
doesn't mean that it's not a problem and
even now we we have problems like you
know the camera that we order doesn't
come with the appropriate lens cap or
whatever my dad won't talk to me
you know yeah it's just different
problems those are two different
problems for sure you want to talk about
that and then we'll talk about some
perspective stuff um let's talk about
the perspective stuff first and then I
can kind of talk about well it doesn't
matter where we start where do you want
to start you want me to start oh yeah
you can't you came to me and said hey uh
you know you and I we had a really good
podcast about parents yes it was episode
142 does that sound right Sean yes well
right it was a great episode I kind of
you know put everything on the table
with my relationship with my dad had a
funeral for the relationship I wished
you had and it really was healing like I
felt better afterwards but
I came to you talking about how I was
waking up on a regular basis angry very
very angry at bailing yeah every single
day waking up angry at man if it wasn't
just for you know my dad's beliefs or
the if it wasn't for the organization
that he follows like him and I could
have this really good relationship and
it would make me angry because I had
this in my head like oh man if if he
would just only if you would just only
do this one thing or if he would just
only see this one point then him and I
could have this amazing relationship and
it's that podcast that we had it was a
great podcast and I feel like I feel
like it was um it was very therapeutic
and it was I'm sure that it helps some
people but the problem that I had with
that episode was I didn't I still didn't
have a clear answer right like I had an
answer that was helping me move forward
but I didn't have a clear answer and
waking up every morning angry that is an
indicator that was an indicator for me
like something is wrong I have to every
single morning go through these
perspectives and that's where you and I
started talking about this so I would
basically wake up every morning and then
have to sit there and and deal with this
anger that I had in the way and the way
that go ahead talk about what because
you had a longer-term solution I think
to me I parse this out and I really like
both ingredients here these perspectives
that I want to talk about here there are
four different perspectives that I
presented to you they are helpful in the
short term correct to help you like like
okay realize it's not as bad as I'm as
I'm playing up online right but then
there's also a longer term solution that
you talked about with your therapist and
we can talk through that as well sure
let's get to the short-term so because I
think what's important it's like how do
we change our state right now and then
well then we let's talk about how do we
change it longer-term how do we change a
long term perspective yes and so the
short term perspective you know for me
it was something as simple and we talked
about this on a podcast I was having a
crappy morning a few podcasts ago like
the morning just wasn't going well and
and I didn't sleep well and
like there was all these I wanted to get
to the office earlier to prepare more
and it just didn't happen but then I
almost stepped in this huge pile of dog
[ __ ] and that's why I'm laughing ladies
and gentleman is because I'm looking
down at the show Josh does a really nice
job preparing these notes before every
podcast and the show starter the first
note on there is dog [ __ ] so so so you
almost stepped in dog [ __ ] right and and
I realized that day like okay it's a
shitty morning but it could be literally
shittier because I could have stepped in
dog and then last week I'm walking in
down my hallway and no one in my
apartment on my floor has a dog that I'm
aware of but there is just dog [ __ ] all
over the hallway Wow and like these huge
it looks like you know some Mastiff was
there or something but the funny thing
is I saw this really old woman maybe in
her like mid-80s getting on the elevator
as I was getting off and she had this
like dog that was you know it wasn't a
very big dog it had to be this dog she
just didn't notice that he was just
crapping all over the hallway and and
it's like that's terrible but it could
have been worse I'd always I could you
know I could have fallen in it I could
be on my shoe or whatever and that's
that's the sort of funny perspective
change just realizing like no matter how
bad something is it could be worse you
could have stepped in [ __ ] but then
there are other like serious perspective
perspective shifts you know were talking
about there's a pastor who I follow on
social media his name is Judas Smith he
runs a church in Seattle and I really
like some of the the the stories that he
tells and he talks about these these
perspectives that we have and how we set
ourselves up for disappointment he was
giving this story about a friend of his
Michael Porter Jr who who was drafted in
in the most recent NBA Draft and now a
year ago or maybe even six months before
the draft he was projected to be number
one in the draft like just really solid
basketball player and they're fairly
centers gonna go number one if he didn't
go to number one he was deaf they're
gonna be in the top two or three but
pretty sure he's gonna be number one but
as the draft comes around they
we'll find out he has a slight back
injury and so he starts to become more
questionable even though he's one of the
best players going to the draft that
year and and so the draft light comes
around and Jude is all happy because
it's like oh we're gonna get drafted the
night even though you know he's a 40
year old guy in Seattle who doesn't play
basketball but he's like I might you
know it's like if if you were going to
be an NBA Draft where I was gonna be an
NBA Draft all of a sudden we'd be really
excited for each other right and and you
would feel like you were being drafted
into the NBA if I was yes and I still
have hopes I'm still holding out me too
man I'm rooting for you waiting for the
Utah Jazz to call any day now anyway so
the draft night comes around and first
pick he doesn't get drafted second third
pick doesn't get drafted and they're
like okay what's going on here make it
down the top seven the top seven or like
the really good players doesn't get
drafted in the top seven make it to
eight nine ten now the lottery only has
14 players and then beyond that it's
just a second sequential thing but so
they make it to number 12 doesn't get
your Aven umber 13 doesn't get drafted
and then for the 14th pick the Denver
Nuggets picked Michael Porter Jr and and
all of a sudden it's like oh wow
this guy was supposed to be number one
yeah this high everyone had this
expectation for him everyone who knew
him was like you're gonna be the top
draft pick of of the year expectations
yeah I'll tell you what hey pay your
crippling right set us up and so they're
interviewing him afterward and it's it's
almost like this backhanded compliment
it's like all you got drafted but it's
in a disappointing that you didn't make
it to number one he just looked at the
first interview and he was like oh no
like I I don't deserve anything mm-hmm
yeah I I think it's just a blessing that
I get to be here I get to play in the
NBA next year how awesome is that
yeah and shifting that around like wow
the standard here is I get to play in
the NBA by the way I'm a first-round
draft pick how awesome is that
I love that dude he doesn't deserve
anything it's like I feel like a lot of
a lot of my woes came from these these
expectations I had these things that I
felt I deserved worse felt that I was
entitled to yes and just that's a
beautiful example of how the less we
feel were entitled to the lower
expectations are but the higher the
standards yes we can take this
experience that yeah everyone else is
looking at oh poor you we're so sorry
for you and we don't have to necessarily
feel that way and his standard is I'm
gonna play basketball to the best of my
ability yeah regardless of what the the
outcome is with yeah what draft thick I
am right because here's the thing the
Rookie of the Year one of the rookies a
year last year played for the Utah Jazz
Donovan Mitchell and he was drafted 27th
Wow and now everyone's like man he
should have been 1st or 2nd right and
and all you have to do is prove yourself
with the high standards yeah because
otherwise um say you get drop how many
people have been drafted number two or
number three or even number one and they
amounted to nothing every year don't get
me started on the Bengals right and I
think that's the point is I do have high
expectations for the people but if they
don't have the standards if it doesn't
work out then what's it worth anyway and
so I think sometimes right we we talk
about what you deserve what you're
entitled to I think with your parent a
situation with your situation with your
dad maybe there were times where you
felt you see other people with great
parents yeah I think about my partner
Rebecca and she like grew up on this
idyllic childhood with two parents who
stayed marry they're still married right
now
yeah lived on a farm middle-class and
lay you know I should be I should have
that too we're entitled to that right
that's what I should have no you
shouldn't have anything yeah I'm lucky
enough to be here yeah exactly man
I mean if we're entitled to anything so
I asked this question to people all the
time because it is an interesting
question I don't know the answer to it
but I do think that we probably are born
with some entitlements and I've heard
people say when I asked him the question
like what do you think we're entitled to
people will say oh you know what clean
water
maybe clean air which we you have to
fight for that stuff
I mean we hardly get that but but the
best answer I got was this dude in
Ireland back when Mariah and I were
there and I think I was like September
of 2015 maybe so long ago but I asked
them we're sitting at the pub and I'm
like you know I got a question I like to
ask people when you seem like you'd have
a good answer to this what do you feel
like we are born entitled to wit when we
are born on this earth what are we
entitled to and he looked at me he was
like peace mmm to be left alone and I
was like dude that is good man like that
is that is absolutely good but but but
to your point though of entitlements
like there's nothing that we are born
into this world that says you have to
have this you need to have that you are
entitled to have this and and yes that
goes with with having awesome parents
like I really wish I had awesome parents
like Mariah has or like Bex has I wish
that we had these awesome flourishing
relationships and they've gotten better
over the years sure um but like with my
mom like I am connecting with her in a
way that I never thought that we would
actually be able to connect with my dad
it's it's kind of going the opposite way
but my point is is that I can work
towards having good parents and I can
put that on me
and do as much work as I can and support
them as much as I can and be a good son
as much as I can but just because I show
them respect just because I go out of my
way to appreciate accept them to support
them doesn't necessarily mean that I'm
entitled to get it back now I get to
choose how much energy and how much of
my resources I put into those
relationships right but just because I
do X Y & Z yes there's a possibility
that a B and C will happen but nothing
nothing in this world and titles a B and
C to happen yeah and even the things you
talked about with I mean to me I would
love to think that it's a right that we
have clean air clean water and peace
like to me those seem like fundamental
but right there are plenty of cavemen
who didn't have access to clean water or
the air was messed up cuz a meat-eor hit
or whatever yeah they were even even
back then they weren't entitled to it
and peace by the way human existence has
been violent for all of human history
until very recently yeah we're if you go
to who
it was I think it's steven pinker and
enlightenment now is that the book yeah
so in there he writes about how if you
go to South Side Chicago and it's
extremely violent violent you go to
over-the-rhine in Cincinnati in the late
90s second most violent neighborhood in
the country you go to West Dayton today
or you go to any any any neighborhood in
North America that is a developed we're
a very developed relatively peaceful
nation but there are neighborhoods that
are extremely violent it's over 600
people were were killed in South South
Chicago last year now if you go out
throughout human history that was
actually the norm right South Side
Chicago was the norm throughout human
history the anomaly is us right now like
we're here we're here in Los a safe part
of Los Angeles yeah it's funny to think
man this is the safest time in human
history right like it is the most
peaceful time there there is one war
going on right now in the Western
Hemisphere right it's like the drug war
with late I don't I don't know where
somewhere in South America that's going
on but besides that I mean it is this is
one of the most peaceful times in in
history for sure and so the things we
think of as an as anomalies now it's
actually the opposite yeah we don't
we're not even entitled to peace even
though we we feel like we should be
right yeah again that helped low user
perspective oh yeah yeah I want to
differentiate when I say peace I don't
mean like peace on earth I do mean being
left alone as far as that goes but
you're right like even even that point
that maybe some people go and you know
going to move into a cabin on the side
of a mountain in the middle of nowhere
Montana then they are left alone but by
and large you're right man like that is
not something that every single person
on this earth can can expect and even
they will not be left alone you know try
not to pay your taxes and really in that
in that cabin absolutely you will be
forced into a violently into a jealous
jail cell yeah and so even that we're
not and so it just really shifts our
perspective on on entitlements right now
the next thing that I saw was on Joe
Rogan's podcast you and I were talking
about a guy named Michael Scott Moore he
wrote a book about for almost three
years I think was two years and eight
he was captured by Somali pirates it's
crazy
2014 I think is when this happened and
so and he was certain he was going to
die basically because they wanted 20
million dollars in order to return him
he's just a journalist you know it's
like I don't make any money like didn't
you say he laughed when they said 20
million dollars no I called your close
relatives tell them you want 20 million
dollars he was like yeah and I mean the
first thing I did was they broke his
hand they hit him in the face with a
with a shotgun but or ak-47 but er what
and and basically fed him crap and like
he developed all kinds of like
autoimmune issues and I mean dying
essentially yeah and then eventually he
he's able to get out through a whole
negotiation process and and now that
he's like I mean he went through and
surprised still does go through a
traumatic PTSD yeah and has recovered
mostly but even like sleeping at night
is difficult for him but he's like I
realize now like the things that used to
make me upset like getting stuck in
traffic right it could be worse you
could be kidnapped by Somali pirates
yeah I like this is anyway hands broken
yeah this is great compared to yeah and
every night they chained him to a bed
and so like it's hard for him to sleep
because like he gets anxiety around like
if it's nighttime that means that's the
time where I'm getting chained to a bed
yeah and I may or may not get beaten
tonight Wow and so that perspective
shift just thinking about that it was
like oh yeah and then the the last story
that you and I talked about and this was
really unfortunate J Alston from our
documentary minimalism tiny house guy
last week was killed by Isis it sounds
so weird later yeah I mean we only got
to see him a couple times
and I I mean I've communicated with him
via email and text
and I always thought like I you know
hang out whenever we go to DC if he was
in DC at the same time so he and his his
wife or partner they decided we're gonna
travel the world we're gonna biker right
there really passion about biking and
they've done long bike trips before and
they wanted to go around the world on a
bike trip right and so they decided hey
now's the time they quit their jobs he
he had someone take care of his tiny
house for him that same tiny house it's
in the documentary and they've been
blogging about their experiences sharing
on Instagram taking photos and day 365
there in the country it's not
Turkmenistan it's country right next to
it right above Afghanistan starts with
the tea I forget the name sorry yeah
yeah it's it's one of the ministers
insert the word here Sean yeah hole fix
no no Sean Sean I'm Jordan on the on the
episode we'll put the name of the
country on right and right here and
anyway he was he and his his girl for
wife were biking with five other
people's a group of seven of them biking
through country she's absolutely
gorgeous so looking at the pictures but
it's also really difficult their journey
was difficult you know it's cold
sometimes at hot and their their
backpacking and they're on their bikes
and they get flat tires yeah people
accidentally run them off the road
sometimes because there's different
customs in different countries anyway
they're with us this pact of seven
people on their bicycles and all of a
sudden a van just swerves and hits all
seven of them all throw they get out of
the van and just start stabbing them to
death don't believe it what's so tragic
man and my heart goes out to all of his
family and friends I mean that's such a
tragic thing yeah and I was I was
talking to someone someone from the New
York Times reached out to me and I'm
just asking me about him and I was
talking to her on on the phone about it
and I was I was both grateful like that
we had the opportunity to to know him
but I was also grateful we had the
opportunity like to live this this dream
this
this passion of his it's so unfortunate
that it led to what it led to
but he lived the last year of his life
doing what they wanted to do and it
wasn't easy no it was it was difficult
but it was simple and they chose to
leave behind the life that was not
fulfilling and lived that last year and
it reminded me of our friends stand and
we've actually done an episode about
about stand me you and in podcast Sean
we all worked with back in the corporate
world one of one of our closest friends
yeah and he died at 30 was he 36 or 37
he was I think 36 yeah yeah maybe 30
yeah we and he had a heart attack
tragically young yeah and died and but
he like he lived a life that a lot of
people wouldn't have lived at all and
like in that attenuated life there was
real life it was real living yeah and so
the essay and we'll put a link to the
essay in the show notes it's called live
like Stan and it it is it was sort of a
a tribute to his life but realizing like
wow like Jay or like Stan like we could
die any any day yeah any moment ya know
so these these perspectives and many
other perspectives that that I would use
to kind of get over that anger that I
was feeling in the morning it helped and
it is verily yeah it helps helps reframe
the day but when I talked to you about
it I was at a point where reframing was
not working it was it was working but it
was working less and less you can't keep
putting band-aids on the wound right and
I feel like I'd wake up in the morning
I'd be angry I put a bandaid on it and
then like the band a start to come off
and then I put like another band-aid on
it right and then by the end of the day
I just got these layers of band-aids so
continue that metaphor it's you have to
bandage the wound before you can get to
the hospital so be sure and these
perspective shifts are the the temporary
band yeah help out but let's talk about
the long-term perspective show yeah so
um so yeah I mean long story short man I
got ahold of a therapist a referral
through our physician dr. Ryan green and
dude it's funny like one-hour therapy
like how it really helped me reframe the
way I looked at the relationship so up
into this point it was
I don't talk a lot about my upbringing
with Jehovah's Witnesses I don't talk
aboutyou OVAs witnesses too much because
I really want to respect people's
beliefs and I really want to respect
people's values and I don't I try to not
talk about that organization the
watchtower tract society I try to not
talk about that in a negative light
because it's just like any other
religion in the sense that it has you
know a group of people with a a bolita
set belief of dogmatix or am i repeating
myself there but yeah there's an
ideology and and it works for my dad and
that's great but I always looked at the
reason why I'm practicing it is because
I always looked at the problem with my
dad and I was this society and I would
always tell myself man if it wasn't for
the watchtower and tract society if it
wasn't for their interpretation of the
Bible then my dad and I would have a
really really great relationship and
that is where I was getting stuck for
two reasons one I don't want to look at
any organization and be it and feel
anger or resentment yeah and plus that
doesn't feel right to me anyway to like
sit there and blame an organization know
the organization is making my dad do
this like that just doesn't feel right
to me so sure talking this through the
therapist yeah it was it was a great man
he just helped me to kind of realize
that yeah man like my dad he is who he
is right and like the the religion that
he is in he uses he uses that as a tool
to be a bad dad he's a bad dad who uses
the the religion to bludgeon you but if
it weren't for the religion he would
find something else to bludgeon me with
and well the thing too is like well the
the the the therapist was like there are
other people in this religion that are
in similar circumstances to what you and
your father in right and he's like and
they they're still able to maintain
decent relationships but they're kids
right and I'm like yeah you're
absolutely right like this is not this
is not a
this is the the organization is not a
the problem it is a symptom of who my
dad really is right that makes any sense
he's looking for the problem right so so
yeah long story short um it feels like
it's just having that one hour
conversation that was on Monday so
today's Thursday this is just four days
ago I haven't woken up angry one time I
mean I do wake up and like it hurts and
I'm like God I wish like I could just
call my dad and be like hey I love you
man how's it going when are we going on
that scuba diving trip but but like I
you know will wake up and like have
those random thoughts but instead of me
getting angry because I used to just be
like oh just see if you were just if you
would just see how misled he is and and
and it's like I don't have that anymore
because it's not about him being misled
right it's just about him being a bad
dad I'm like that's okay man like I it's
funny because I've always what's ok
because you're not entitled to a good
dad yeah and you know I always looked at
like the relationship with my mother
back in the 8th grade when just you know
[ __ ] hit the fan with with with that
side of my family I got blamed yeah as
in junior high I got blamed for a lot of
what happened and I was able and I was
able to in junior high look at the
relationship with my mom I'd be like you
know what I don't know why I'm being
blamed for this stuff right now
I don't know why any of this is my fault
in fact it's not my fault and it turns
out that you know my mom's perspective
is just wrong and she's just not able to
be a good parent right now and I was
able to move on and it's like I don't
know why it took me until 37 years old
to realize that with my dad but it was
through this therapy session that
totally helped me to kind of to just
accept that really yeah but you know I
guess the other thing to get out of this
whole experience and the reason why I'm
sharing it is because if if there is
someone out there who is waking up with
a with you know some kind of pain or
some kind of inks on a regular basis
yeah the temporary band-aids will work
well temporarily it is so important to
go get the help that you need
and it's
and it's not like like our conversations
help in fact when people when people
reach out to me for mentoring a lot of
the times they will tell me hey Ryan I
know I have a lot of good friends to
talk to and family to talk to but I know
what what your personality is like I
respect your opinion and your advice
so I just want to get an unbiased
opinion on a matter right so I can you
know was someone that I respect and it
was the same thing with a therapist it's
like I want to you know well yeah the
other thing yeah I wanted to talk to
someone who I respected and he was a
great recommendation from dr. Ryan green
who like really talked him up but the
other thing too is like I'm thinking all
right Ryan I have got the typical the
stereotypical like Freud mommy and daddy
issues so why don't I go and do the
stereotypical treatment for it right and
it turns out like it's it's a stereotype
for reason yeah and it was helpful and
guess what if it wasn't helpful you
wasted an hour of your life and a little
bit of money yeah and at least you're
one step closer to figuring out what the
long-term perspective shift is so what
the reason I I bring these these two
different solutions up is getting the
short-term perspective shift is
important as long as you're willing to
do something about it long-term as well
and so finding finding what that change
is for you it could be as simple as as
reframing the idea that lay it's not a
bad religion necessarily it's a bad
parent yeah it's it was yeah was
reframing the the way I looked at my dad
like instead of using something else to
blame for my dad and I his relationship
being able to look at my dad and just be
like dude this is not it has nothing to
do with religion this has nothing to do
the watchtower track Society this has
everything to do with you as a person
because of worf religion he would use
geography or money or any other excuse
to to beat you over the head with that
right and any other sort of resource or
ideology that that it was useful and
because you the conversation you and I
had like even when you're growing up and
you were being a good Jehovah's Witness
oh yeah yeah going out going
door-to-door on a regular basis may
every single every single meeting which
is just another term for going to church
and dude like when I was there I think
they cut it back but when I was there it
was like three days a week going for an
hour or two hours yeah I was doing
everything I was supposed to do and even
then he found fault still found a way
house Intel I'll do whether cuz I was
working for him at the time so there's
always you know riding me at work with
every little thing that he could find
yeah I mean just insert random not in a
little paper no not in a loving way not
in a way that helps you grow yeah I mean
just you know any any random excuse you
could think of in a wallpaper and
painting business to like criticize
someone like he was just right on top of
it and I understand because this he is
raising his standards for me and I and I
understand that um you know he's going
to try and get me to get to those
standards yeah but to your point the
standards that he's trying to get to
trying to get me to now I was already
there right and he still was a bad dad
and I think about my sister it's the
same thing I mean she was doing you know
it's like my dad would be like okay you
need to to my sister you need to go you
need to go door to door more so then she
would and then he'd be like okay that's
great you're doing good but you need to
go even more now so then she upped her
hours to you know 30 hours a month or 40
hours I forget what it like what the
what the what the the timeframe is that
they require to to but they called what
I'm not gonna get into the jargon but my
point is is that so then yeah she go out
door-to-door more and then my dad leg
that's great now make sure that you are
dating someone when she got to the age
to today make sure you're dating someone
that is is in the watchtower on track
Society so then she would great she
found someone who was in the washer on
track decided well it turns out he
wasn't he wasn't enough of a person for
her to date because he wasn't an elder
in the in the in the church or he was so
there was always there is always this
standard that my dad would have we meet
it and then he raises it and that is a
symptom of him that is not a symptom of
anything else which by the way is great
if you are raising standards for reason
that's what we should be doing
when we have these arbitrary standards
or not even standards anymore
it becomes an unrealistic expectation
yeah and it's always going to be the
next thing that is out of reach I'm
always gonna find something that is out
of reach for you yeah it's it's the all
you can dunk on a 13 foot rim hello
you're 14 here's 13 and a half yeah dude
it's it's always like raising that bar
but dude it's it's totally okay to raise
one standards it's okay for me to raise
my standards I'll raise my standards
every day if I can but I will never
raise your standards for you I will
never go out of my way to make you feel
bad yeah because I've set a standard for
you in my head and you're not there
like you're my best friend dude like I
will support you no matter what and if
you need help if you ask me for help
with your standards that you set for
yourself great I'll help you but I'm not
gonna come to you and say these are my
standards and you're not living up to
them and you should feel bad about it
man that sounds like a whole lot of
shitty relationships yeah a lot of
shitty relationships that's why they're
shitty is because we try to impose our
standards our beliefs our resources our
desires our and even our values onto
other people yeah and we do that not
only are we it's not setting the example
because that's not what your dad was
doing I'm gonna set the example for you
in fact it was often the opposite yeah
it was do as I say not as I do
and and by doing that by by trying to
impose my value if I'm living up to them
if I'm imposing on you you're not it's
it's the thing that I always say is you
know people don't hate change
they hate being changed right and
because we all like certain change like
I got promotion at work or wow we got a
new podcast studio that's a change like
those are changes that we eerily embrace
because we went after it right whereas
the difference is if someone says all
right guys all right the minimalist
we're putting you in a new podcast
studio like wait what yeah or or you
know you're getting a demotion at were
or whatever like in fact I took a
demotion to work once remember I I
eliminated the job that I was in so I
come back into another job that was more
ideal for me yeah
and that was great but if someone were
to force me into it it's like being
changed we don't like being changed so
trying to change someone is never going
to work at least not long-term you know
it's funny man I support people's values
and beliefs as much as possible go out
of my way to not just support but
appreciate the differences in people's
values and beliefs but what I don't
support is when it is affecting the
well-being of other people like that's
where that's where I will step up and be
like hey you're insane yeah well first
of all thank you for sharing that story
I think we should probably dive into
some of these questions give me another
three hour long podcast our first
question is from Elise in Richmond
Virginia I'm embarrassed to say that
it's taken me this long to realize that
minimalism isn't about stuff a
decluttered home isn't my end goal here
a focus and value driven life is and I
realized this last week the decluttering
the trips to Goodwill the reduced use of
my cell phone for mindless activities
all of those were easy for me and I'm
daunted by the idea of pushing forward
to alter my negative habits and treat my
time as a valuable resource it's been
investing in my well-being and the
well-being of others so I'm hoping to
glean some encouragement from your own
experiences have either of you struggled
with certain aspects of minimalism and
if so why and how did you overcome them
all right so so Ryan she she said that
minimalism isn't about the stuff right I
agree with that but I also think it's an
important first step
yeah it is minimalism sort of a response
to this overindulgent consumerism it it
is an old solution from the Stoics and
the last years ago major world religions
and the transcendentalist like Thoreau
and Emerson Emerson and and so it is an
old solution to a new problem and that
problem is is this excess that we're
dealing with right and she said like
decluttering or her home isn't the end
goal I think for some people it is and
that's okay like that could be the end
goal and ultimately it will lead to
other benefits you might feel calm or
it's easier to clean your
sir you have more time we have more
money you have more resources you just
feel better yeah and and that can be a
fine Angola now for hers what she's
saying is she wants to go beyond that
right and and so she mentioned time as a
resource now you and I we talk all the
time about time and attention being your
most precious resources and you know
I've had a few conversations on it so
I've been working on finishing up this
essay and it's not done yet
although by the time this podcast comes
out it will be on our website cool but I
wanted to read this and I wanted to get
your your thoughts on these five
resources now the version that you read
on our website will probably be a little
bit different from this once podcast
Shawn copy edits it but it's called your
five most precious resources
a simple life involves perhaps above
anything else the deliberate use of
resources which is why we fashioned a
handy acronym to help you identify and
budget your most precious resources and
that acronym is steam st e a m and the
first Resource is skills so skills you
may possess certain inborn talents like
Hawking strength graceful agility or a
beautiful voice but your talent is
blunted if you don't develop it into
useful skills to get good at anything to
create something significant requires
competence which is developed slowly day
after day with rigor drudgery and
practice until eventually you've wedded
a skill sure your innate talent might
make it easier to sharpen your skills
but the work is still required hard work
which is why hone skills are in our
infinitely more valuable than wasted
talent besides is there anything more
disappointing than unskilled talent so
so think about the efforts like we all
we all have like certain skills you know
someone who is just like a good
basketball player by Nature yeah I think
of my brother as an example like he
lacked the discipline you know I just
have we were hanging out in Louisville
after our Louisville tour stopped a few
weeks ago and I was talking to him his
his partner Sarah who he's been with for
10 years I just had a kid together and
they she's like so tell me about Jerome
as a kid I'm like he was like crazy
athletic and completely lack the
discipline that he needed to like hone
that into a skill like he had tell he
was dunking in the seventh grade that is
a talent yeah I could get the rim once
upon a time but I couldn't dunk and I
and so for me like I saw that and and he
didn't hone it into a skill though right
and to me like that's always the most
disappointing thing where you have
someone who has this talent you could be
so amazing yeah I remember we played we
played on a church basketball league in
the eighth grade and he would drop 40
points a game sometimes that's great and
and like just because he could and and
but didn't like I didn't want to go to
practice every day to play on the high
school team and he didn't want one and
and I look at that and I'm like there
are other people who don't have that
talent but they're willing to put in the
work to have the to develop the enough
skills to be good enough to at least
play right and you need both to be in a
level like the NBA level you need both
the talent and the skills but skill is
is this resource that we all are able to
have just like money we can all have
money you can go work for an hour and
make at least you seven dollars and
fifty cents that's a resource $7.50
would be that resource a skill the same
thing you work for an hour ten hours 100
hours 10,000 hours to develop the skill
set and then all of a sudden you have
that reason and that is a resource
you've developed as long as you keep
using it doesn't necessarily go away I
think about really great stand-up comics
we're gonna go see some comedy tonight
yeah Tom Segura is gonna be there and
Christina pea and Chris D'Elia yeah Marc
Maron
these are people will put in their
10,000 hours they've developed a skill
yeah and they can get rusty overtime if
they stop using it but they've developed
that skill it's not a talent I'm gonna
get on stage and all of a sudden I've
got this there might be some people Dave
Chappelle apparently like
since day one has been like good in
front of a crowd yeah but very rarely
does that happen yeah and so that's a
resource that we have we don't think
about Lisa's talking about wasting her
time as a resource but also think about
like what does that at that time
resource get you you could use that to
hone a skill for the longest time you
and I worked in the corporate world and
we developed a particular skill set of
someone what was about running a
business and that's still helpful for us
yeah there's a lot of things that
transferred over from there absolutely
maybe you know 10 to 20 percent of it
but but a lot of it was like wasted
developing skills that we didn't
necessarily need or want to develop
right learning manipulation and learning
you know way too much about data
measurement and and and brand
recognition yes yeah yeah and things
that were kind of allergic to now that
it's like a skill we developed and
realized like I have an allergy to that
skill right and and so I think it's
really important to think about what
else can I do with what what are the
skills that I can develop because that
is a resource that are gonna keep on
giving it is an asset for you once you
develop thats coming you and I this is
podcast episode 145 but really this is
episode 202 because we've done 67
PostScript episodes as well for the
patreon supporters so so we've done over
200 podcast episodes not to mention all
the live podcast that we haven't
released yeah or the ones that we
recorded and never and never released
them yeah yeah and and in that time we
were able to whet a skill that that you
go back and listen to episode 2 yeah
it's not nearly as good although we had
had several years of speaking experience
before then some of that translates to
being on the mic but now we're able to
sit here and have a conversation or
stand here I should say and have a
conversation
and be much more comfortable with doing
that on a microphone yeah and that is a
skill that only happens over time there
are some people who have the gift of gab
you're one of them I think I I certainly
am NOT
not on this podcast that's not true I
but but I mean part of it has to do with
with knowing when to speak and when it's
appropriate whatever they're other
people have the gift the gift of gab and
it's the curse of gab really they're
they're just speaking speaking speaking
like Beck's and I were eating at this
restaurant fish 101 down in Encinitas
the other day and this guy next to us he
was just talking to everyone and he can
either take that talent that he has and
in fact after when I when I left I like
this guy we either honed that into a
skill where he's gonna be great at
selling something hopefully it's
something meaningful Wow I saw him
talking to this older couple I wouldn't
been surprised if by the end of the
night he's in their house selling them
real estate or something or he's gonna
take that that same talent and he's
gonna be at a bar every night talking
about his woes to everyone who won't
maybe listen to it yeah and that's what
talent gets you it gets you either way
you can keep using that talent and a non
skilled way or you can you can develop
it you can sharpen it into a skill yeah
and I think that's that's really
important especially when she talks
about her values are the next to the
next resource here in this acronym steam
ste am is time it's striking that we
refuse to pay a couple bucks to listen
to a podcast but then we'll hand over
hours of our day willy-nilly to anyone
who provides us with quote free content
but of course free isn't actually free
if you're spending your time there's no
refund on poorly spent time yeah amen
so spend it wisely that's one of those
resources that is not renewable right
you can spend it developing a skill or
you can spend it you're just wasting it
all day and I you know on a bar or doing
drugs or whatever it happens to be and
there's nothing wrong with periodic
pacification we're gonna talk about that
a little bit later but but if it if it's
leading to
wasted time like all the time and you're
not doing anything with it or reminded
me of this cartoon I have here Ryan this
is from The New Yorker
I'll give us to you Jordan after or
maybe you can put it on the YouTube
video there's a like some corporate guys
in suits but they're all like they have
you see it there they have a describe
that to me um it is it looks like a band
uh-huh that their whole shtick is
dressing up like they work in the
corporate world and what's the CAPTCHA
are you ready to engage with rock-based
god oh my god I got a New Yorker cartoon
Jordan oh hang that T maybe you can
throw that in the video no faking it are
you ready to engage in rock based
content yeah it's like wait a minute
like that that's that's that feels like
that's what we're the Internet has
enabled us to not put out like
meaningful creations how you and I
talked about it bleh
I don't want to get good at a skill I
don't spend my time on this skill I'd
rather just engage rock based content
instead of putting out rockin good rock
and roll music let's put together some
rock based content I love that like if a
band actually like that was their whole
persona they just like dress but they're
really really good though but like
that's their whole shtick is like and
they look like they just got done
working a nine-to-five are you ready for
this rock bass content but then it would
be awesome music well it's so you
remember in the late 90s I graduated
high school
half a year early and so I went off to
audio engineering school this is back
when you actually would record this is
99 reel-to-reel tapes right yeah and
classic and well I I recorded for this
jazz trio from the University or from
Ohio State University they would come
down the Chillicothe Ohio which is where
the school was we had like six different
studios there and we
and I didn't learn anything there really
that is still useful today because now
we use like a you know a little recorder
for the podcast we don't need the board
dr. Dre board or whatever but it was
useful there because you had to mic up
all the drum stuff so we had this jazz
trio and they're like these college guys
and they have these like khaki shorts on
and tucked in polo shirt is horse logo
on them that's great and they're playing
the jet and it's really good right but
their side project for school
mm-hmm was a death metal band I loved it
it was called the priests murderers
that's great it makes me think of a
Alexisonfire
or Alexa on fire yeah yeah city in color
yeah yeah that's that's great dude yeah
Alexisonfire i think yeah yeah yeah and
and yeah the city of color sort of came
out of that right um but it was it was
like this there was this dissonant so
you'd hear the music you hear the death
metal or you know the crazy doesn't by
the way death metal we're good good
death metal whatever that means requires
significant amount of proficiency yeah
Sean's a drummer you can attest that
trying to do the death metal drums I
mean it's like it's crazy and like I
mean it's a requires a lot of grunting
and screaming into a microphone but the
but you actually have to have good
vocals though to do it yeah I think so
the elite singer in the family yeah yeah
and so when I think about what they were
creating there like there was this
dissonance and that's what that that
cartoon was like it's like they were
creating death metal content yeah well a
it was just a side project that was fun
for them like they didn't take it
serious in fact it was kind of a gag for
them the show hey we're really good at
music we can be a jazz trio or we can be
I don't yeah we can be death metal and
so yeah they were using their time to
sort of shape multiple skills there the
next the next one in this this is one
you and I have talked about and I've
realized that it recently especially as
I've talked about my health problems
I've got a lot of energy back recently
yeah that's the next one energy is the
next most precious resource we often
live our lives as if we're a deflating
balloon bouncing aimlessly from our
inboxes to our television sets to our
social media profiles allowing other
people's prior
to dictate our actions it feels
productive to be busy but meaningful
tasks rarely reside on our to-do list if
we focus our energy wisely though then
we can float purposely through life
otherwise we're just deflating yeah I
think sometimes especially when we have
limited amounts of energy it feels
easier to like well I'm just gonna I'll
just be on the inbox or I'll watch the
TV or whatever like i'll expend less
energy you're still expending the energy
you have only so many waking hours and
how we use that energy is really
important if and the other word that you
might want to use for that instead of
energy is focused what am i focusing my
energy on and it requires more energy to
be focused but that's how you get
something meaningful
yeah and that line thereof meaningful
tasks rarely reside on our to-do list
Shawn you can put that as minimal
maximum in the show notes the next one
is one we always talk about attention I
think it's the most precious resource or
it's certainly up there in a world
filled with glowing screens pop-up ads
and multi-platform media everyone is
vying for access to our ever contracting
attention spans advertisers have figured
out that the shortest route to your
checking account is by way of your
attention so they'll do almost anything
to grab it I mean you think about
although the pop ups and the bottom pop
ups and the I mean they'll do anything
to get the attention how do I get eight
seconds of your time yeah I need it
right now right now it's crazy but maybe
these corporations are reckless with our
attention because we are so careless
with it ourselves
amen dude that's yeah we are we we as a
society allow these tactics to work and
because we allow them to work the
corporation's continue to use these
tactics I totally agree with you man
yeah absolutely and so if we want to
live deliberately we mustn't squander
our mind share on every interruption so
it's best to subscribe to mute and to
walk away from anything that's not
adding value to our lives yeah and the
reason I'm reading this essay for a
lease here is she has her question is
about living a more deliberate life and
getting past this stuff and I think it's
the stuff because the stuff takes up so
much of our attention yeah not just the
stuff that we have that we have to take
care of right but the stuff that we're
think about bringing into our lives and
shopping and the neuroses I mean Bex is
buying a new car right now and the the
time and the patience that really goes
into making sure that you get the car
that's gonna last the next five to ten
years right and and making sure you take
it she's taking a couple of mechanics
and it just doesn't check out or
whatever and and and in doing so like
it's a very deliberate purchase but you
want that you want to be deliberate with
it now I'd rather spend 40 hours on that
purchase now than live for the next four
years with her terrible purchase with a
bad decision yeah I'm trying to dig
yourself out of the hole and the last
resource here is money although we often
think of money as the ultimate resource
it is the least important of the five
here in money won't necessarily improve
your life it merely amplifies your
existing behaviors if you have bad
habits more income will make your life
considerably worse yeah you think about
like the people who win the lottery
right and all of a sudden they're dead
or in jail or broken dude my ears my
ex-father-in-law uh-huh he was a
president of a bank in Ohio but a chain
of banks I don't know how many locations
they had but over 20 yeah he told me
that in his tenure as president of that
Bank he saw I think it was five it was
five or six people win the lottery and
one of them one of them did not go
bankrupt and that has to do with habits
yeah so if you have good habits and you
win the lottery you can do some really
great things and and well in the one
example that didn't go bankrupt he said
you know what their secret was they
didn't change anything about their lives
they just continued to live the same
lives right they'd already built for
themselves and that's the amplification
I'm talking about here so and if you're
already a generous person then money can
help you be more loving caring yeah and
consider it you know and then there's a
little PS here at the bottom you could
rejigger our acronym as meats in the 80s
which would be funnier and perhaps more
memorable but let's avoid putting money
first I think it's a thing about
when we put like we think about money is
the ultimate resource and and it's not
necessarily so for Elise the thing that
I that I would say is yeah I struggled
with meaningful management and
prioritization of my most precious
resources I put money first for a long
time and I didn't think about developing
my skills I there would always be time
to do that in the future or I was
careless with my attention I was
careless with my energy I was careless
with with my resources because I
pretended as if they were just infinite
or I'd get to it someday in the future
yeah you know all these resources man
it's I just had this thought that so out
of these five resources time is the one
that we all have in common we all have
24 hours in a day yes now you know some
of us will live longer lives than others
I get that but as far as the time goes
we all wake up we have we have that time
yes if we spend that time if we spend it
- with good habits we like healthy
habits specifically I was thinking this
leads to more energy and more time
potential there right if you live in
healthy life you'll get more time
hopefully yes exactly so yes so healthy
lifestyle yeah I'll give you more time
to give you more energy absolutely
and having more energy will allow you to
have more attention mmm yeah because
what that energy is what you focus on
and if you're focused your energy then
your attention is going to be better
used and then your attention if you use
it right you can really develop some
really awesome skills yes and then if
you develop these skills to a point
where you're adding value to a lot of
people's lives and you're really really
good at these skills well then you might
be able to make money from it your your
skills will ultimately help people solve
problems dude I mean the because of the
acronym it's not in that order but that
is I think you just uncovered the
meanings of life your job or not not the
meanings of life but the formula for for
living a meaningful life yeah I I think
so man I think in this is based off many
conversations you know I have had and
just trying to get it out there and a
way that's memorable and thinking about
those resource no it's it's beautifully
put man so yeah I mean I as far as my
struggles go man um III did I struggle
with stuff every day still like I
struggle with addiction man like it is
I'm an addictive person like it would be
very easy for me to drink a half a
bottle to a bottle of Jameson every
single day probably not a whole bottle
but but you know what if I if I started
with a half a bottle I probably get to a
bottle eventually yeah you've worked
your way up to it yeah man um narcotics
god dude narcotics sure do make you feel
good I mean it's like a really nice easy
quick fix but man like the the when I
say struggle with those things every day
it might it might because I had struggle
with that stuff so much in my past it
might be something where you know I'm
thinking about relationship with my dad
or something and it's like man you know
what if I could just take a pill right
now that would really just kind of like
mask all that pain or on the on the
other end of the spectrum
drinking is something that I'd love to
celebrate with a drink
well celebrating with 10 drinks is
definitely not healthy but I but if I if
I did not have limitations if I didn't
have good habits then these these things
could certainly end up being a problem
because I think you're talking about the
residue of the past - and that yeah that
always carries forward so what you're
talking about is you talk about some
past habits that have changed right and
so so you well what I understand is like
- in order for for me to keep my life
clear of clutter
it also means keeping my mind clear of
clutter and those things especially
narcotics do not add to the clarity and
it makes it more cluttered if anything
right I mean dr. green last night when
we were when we were all having dinner
he showed us a picture of the dude who I
forget his name from Mighty Ducks but
he's like the goalie and mighty does he
was like this you know chubby fat like
cute kid who was a goalie in this movie
in this kid's movie and he just got
arrested not too long ago for a DUI and
he looks like my grandfather he looks
like the result of a long lived hard
life yeah and and it's not even that way
is long because it's painful right
and and what you're talking about
there's no judgment here it's just a
matter of your identifying yeah
absolutely absolutely the other thing I
struggle with too man is dude I always
want to buy new stuff I wish I could sit
here and say hey listen to our podcasts
read our books yeah and you will never
want to buy anything again ever
you will be you will be free of this
urge to buy stuff that's just not the
case man yeah I mean it's like if
anyone's telling you that they're there
they're probably misleading yeah yeah
absolutely man I mean I think about I
know I talk about Mariah and nice toy to
Carolla a lot but you know I'm saving
money for a new car and I really want to
buy a new Tesla like if I stayed up for
another two years three years I could
probably have $60,000 to drop on a Tesla
right but the problem though is that I
don't have it $60,000 is a lot of money
for me a lot of money for a lot of
people but but my point is is that I'm
not a well going with Dave Ramsey's
suggestion yeah he says you know if
you're if you're a millionaire okay you
can afford to buy a new car you know if
your net worth is more than a million
dollars you can afford the person to
call right by the way the average so
that Chris Hogan has that new book
coming out in January called everyday
millionaires yeah and they did a the
most comprehensive study of millionaires
throughout the the country and more than
10,000 millionaires and by the way when
we say millionaires we're talking a lot
of teachers and nurses we're not talking
about finance guys and and and bankers
and everyday people everyday people and
large percentage of them have made less
than $60,000 a year they yeah our life
absolutely
they've just made good decisions with
the resources they have absolutely but
keep going with the Dave Ramsey things
well when he talks about with
millionaires is you have a million
dollar net worth then you're you're able
to buy a new car but your average
millionaire drives a car that is three
years old or older
right because millionaires didn't become
millionaires but buying a new car every
year yeah you don't become millionaire
by spending your money but but you know
to to at least this questionnaire she
asks you know how you know what kind of
tools do we use to help us through these
these problems we have
in like Dave Ramsey he's one of those
guys like I the book said he that he has
a radio show whatever it may be like
that's a tool that I used to help keep
myself in check so yeah like if I was if
I had a net worth of a million bucks
still would be very hard for me to drop
that type of money on a car but at least
at least I could like here's what I
envision if you know if you and I ever
you know become millionaires um if I
drop sixty thousand dollars on a car I
would have to drop sixty thousand
dollars on building schools in Laos but
right now I'm not in a position to where
I can I can take a hundred twenty
thousand dollars and divide it up like
that right so so because of these
principles because of these tools that I
use like no I'm not gonna go out and buy
a Tesla like I've been talking about buy
a Tesla for a couple years I ain't gonna
do it now I mean unless unless I have an
expendable income if someone drops 10
million dollars on your lap yeah here's
the thing you you and I are like for
example we're helping build the grocery
store you and I are donating over
$20,000 for own money and I would rather
do that then have a Tesla yeah yeah yeah
and yet you could like hoard that money
and say well I'm going to and it'll be
ok it's your money you do whatever the
hell you want with your money yeah and
I'm not sure like this is not me virtue
signaling and I'm not trying to make
anyone feel bad out there for owning a
tussle I just wanna be very clear on
that I'm just answering Elise's question
on the problems that I have mm-hm and
and how I'm able to overcome those
problems that I have but it is through
reasoning like this it's through
different tools that help me to keep
good habits because emotionally it's
really easy to say in the moment man
that'd be great I could figure out a way
to afford the monthly payment on a Tesla
or whatever right yeah and well I could
afford the payment right you just can't
afford the car right there are two more
cartoons I want to share with you Ryan
Oh cartoons so so this is another New
Yorker one Jordan I'll give this to you
afterward you want to describe what this
says but before what you before it says
what it says just describe the room all
right there's a woman walking through it
looks like an apartment door she has a
scolding look on her face and there's a
dude sitting in the middle of an empty
room hardwood floor sitting on the chair
with a smirk so she's yelling he's
smirking in an empty room he came Hurley
wait
the caption says you came home early
just so you could get the chair well
that's great so I think people often
think of minimalism like this right
right I use it yeah I do with that yeah
this is deprivation oh man exactly and
so that's the thing that I want to
communicate here with Elise is yeah
you'll struggle with certain things but
this isn't the answer
having the house with nothing in it is
not what we're going for I mean you were
at my house last night yeah there were
six of us there we had a table with six
of us eating dinner on plate yeah we all
had our own seat almost I was well isn't
that why you were sitting on my lap yeah
yeah but I still had to see that could
it use if I want to Jordan if you want
to put that on on-camera somehow so with
Elise keep that in mind as you're
letting go yes the the cluttering of the
stuff is not the end result because that
would be your end result in fact you had
to get rid of the chair that's too much
stuff right why do you have a chair
you're not a real minimalist without a
chair it's funny man I just had to stop
popping in my head like we always talked
about how someone could rent a dumpster
or throw away all their stuff and still
be miserable in an empty apartment like
the the the minimal is the the exciting
part of minimalism it is the journey
like it is fit is taking this tool and
it's helping one to figure out exactly
what adds value to their life and like
that process the process of doing that
like that is that's the fun part
yeah having it having an empty room with
just a tear in it like that's not much
fun or meaningful for that matter well
for most people but if you want to live
that way I think of our friend Colin
right now who's out getting ready to go
out on tour right now the becoming tour
I think is becoming tour calm he's doing
26 cities in this next year but for the
last two years he's lived in an
apartment they because he's focused on
creating his podcast and he was renting
an apartment in Memphis for the last
year and he got you know the basics he
had a desk and a chair
I'm sure his house his apartment looked
fairly similar to that with a few other
accoutrements right and and in doing
that that's what was appropriate for him
he hadn't he didn't like having company
over and light so he had what worked
just for him it was on space and
that's fine now that he's he's getting
ready to leave he had to even get rid of
some of the stuff so I'm guarantee his
apartment looks really similar to that
right now I'm gonna this is the third
and final cartoon but this reminds me
this card who reminded me of Elise when
I was thinking about her question I saw
this cartoon and I was like this is
where Elise is right now of course you
know Alice in Wonderland right yes this
the title of this one at the top says
Alice and responsibilities land and
she's coming home so there's her she's
walked into her kitchen yeah and
everything that is there it's like the
door says lock me and the umbrella says
put me away and the food on the counter
says cook me and the dishes in the sink
say wash me and the freezer says defrost
me and the fridge says film me and the
window says look through me and the
email and the computer says check me and
the plates on the table say clear us and
the Wow the bottle of alcohol on the
table says don't drink me and the
cupcake on the table says don't eat me
and the bills on the table say pay us
and the the purse in her hand says put
me down and the chairs on her hour at
her kitchen table say wipe us down and
the floor says sweep me that is a genius
cartoon man and they're so good and we
get overwhelmed with these
responsibilities and for me minimalism
is a way not to remove this
responsibilities I'll give this to you
Jordan seeing put that in oh it's a way
to choose yes it's the way it's a way to
pick better responsibilities what am I
going to be responsible about because we
all have to be responsible to something
in someone why not choose those
deliberately instead of just having to
deal with the next responsibility that
fills our life yeah absolutely well at
least I'd love to send you a copy of our
book minimalism live a meaningful life
Sean if you reach out to her and send
her the audiobook version if you like
the the podcast then you'll probably
like the audiobook version of this it's
a relatively short book it's like two
and a half hours long it's our shortest
book and it goes over the five values
the one thing that we didn't talk to you
about is identifying getting really
focused on what your values are because
at least you said you want to be focused
and value value driven
if you want to be value-driven well then
you better be driven by the right values
because it's possible to not have the
right values that are gonna move you
forward and then you're gonna be like
that deflating balloon that we talked
about so we'll give you the audiobook
version of that or if you want the book
book version of the eBook version we'll
be happy to give you a copy of live a
meaningful life in any of those formats
our next question is from Emma in
Mammoth way I'm late I gotta get up
there and snowboard this season Mariah
yeah that's like here it's amazing yeah
I've never been but we'll make it up
there Mammoth Lakes California I spent
here working in corporate America and
that was enough for me
I suffered through it I tested out I'm a
hard dedicated worker I wanted to do a
good job at my job and I did a fantastic
job the company did not want me to leave
when I gave them my notice but I told
them I had to do this for my health
and my mental sanity I knew that what I
was doing was not good for me and I knew
that what I was doing was not
cultivating my passion so how does
someone step back into their discomfort
zone after being in your comfort zone
for a period of time because of how
uncomfortable a job was so how do you
step back into the discomfort zone so
they love that question ma'am and you
know I'm good for you Emma seriously
like that is awesome yeah because what
happens is if we get too comfortable for
too long we I mean there there's a
parody of the couch potato you know you
think of lay I don't have a New Yorker
cartoon to describe it but you can
imagine what it would look like yeah
dude it's the couch potatoes literally
eating a bag of potatoes and and and
there's no real growth in that other
than our waist lines
well contentment does not does not lead
to creation mmm yeah that's pithy put
that in the that is right yeah but
creation leads to contentment amen
Oh boom
and so I think I think we the first
thing you have to do is find what it was
the edge of your comfort zone today and
it's gonna be different for each one of
us right what's the edge of your comfort
zone and step one step beyond that I'm
thinking about I just got one of those
those stationary bikes at home right and
I was going to my initial objective this
month was to ride it every day this
month there in the month of August
I've decided to step back because on the
seventh day I was in so much pain like I
was like I'd should probably take a one
or two day break on this thing you know
cuz you're doing a soul cycle class
literally every day for a month and so
everybody needs to rest yeah my
objective is if I can do it 15 times a
month still a lot 15 SoulCycle sessions
and in one month but what are you doing
you've been to a SoulCycle class with me
before you they have periods of high
intensity its interval training right
you're really heavy for 30 seconds on
heavy heavy heavy oh my god am I gonna
make it it's 20 seconds then how am I
gonna go 10 more seconds at this at this
energy level right yeah you figure a way
to push through but then what do you
have you have another 30 second break
it's on and all so you find that edge of
it's extremely uncomfortable to be doing
that but you're not gonna do it in
perpetuity because then you're going to
break you go too far beyond the comfort
zone and you break however if you find
that edge and you push hard for those 30
seconds or whatever the equivalent is
but then there's the moment of rest to
step back into the comfort zone like
it's not it's not completely rest you're
still pedaling and you're Cadence's is
lowered but you're still moving forward
your resistance is not zero but it's
still some resistance there and that
resistance actually helps us grow inside
the comfort zone and it prepares us for
that discomfort as well well and quite
literally man like that's what exercise
is about it's about giving yourself
resistance so your muscles can grow so
you're you can have good cardiovascular
health
like growing in a healthy way like quite
literally you have to have the
resistance right and by the way there's
you we were talking about this on the
health problems podcast that I did with
with Chris and dr. wood
when we were talking about someone
health problems but when people do it
some of the best sort of training is
really high intensity and then back you
know if you don't want to just go out
and run for two hours straight right at
a medium pace and and he was comparing
it to the the the mental load the medium
cognitive load is what he called it hmm
where it's the opposite of what Cal
Newport talks about with deep work like
really heavy focus for an hour or two a
day it's you nine or level nine or Tim
you can't do more than an hour or two of
that and there are a few exceptions
fiction writers seem to be able to do
three to five hours a lot of them but
but but for the most part and you have
this heavy cognitive load but then you
have to back off and you have to go look
at a tree or something for a while so it
doesn't require that that heavy
cognition and I think the same is going
to be true here for Emma and is is
you're gonna have to find that
discomfort and then whatever that is
it's a step beyond the comfort zone it's
not pain
don't confuse discomfort with pain
they're two different things we don't
want you to suffer we want you to get a
little bit uncomfortable that's where
you're gonna grow ya going with your
bike analogy it's like being on the bike
is uncomfortable yeah but then it
started become painful right when you
weren't on the bike and there's a clear
distinction we're like oh like this is
not growing this is hurting it's not
good for me right so he's not growing
that's another that's another beautiful
minimal maxim their podcast Shawn I a
man you know I want to encourage I'm
gonna start small she's got a practice
getting back into her discomfort zone so
does that mean you know going to the gas
station and asking for a refree refill
on her gas does that mean
public speaking does it mean writing you
know that first song and singing it in
front of you know her partner a friend I
don't know what that means for her but
my point is is that she can find these
fairly banal experiences they have no
real negative consequences exactly not
bail with an up in Alba 9 tonight
so these fairly with an up and all yeah
hopefully have an up thicket but I can't
be been on but doesn't necessarily have
to be but yeah you can find these benign
experiments these these way to practice
kind of being in your discomfort zone
Emma and the more you practice the
better you get at it
there I love the talk Jia Jian I think
is how you pronounce his name he talks
about his story with practicing failure
I know I've recommended this before on a
podcast like several several podcasts
ago but we saw him at the world
domination summit I think was back in
2000 in the most mid 2013 something like
yeah but anyway he just does a really
good job of talking about how he doesn't
talk about practicing being
uncomfortable what he talks about his
practicing failure but he gives an
amazing talk about how he went out and
tried to fail on purpose so he could get
comfortable with it and I think it's a
very appropriate talk for Emma where she
could translate his advice on failing
I'm practicing failing too practicing
being uncomfortable right yeah right
yeah and the other thing I'm thinking
about she left the corporate world right
she left that corporate jobs something
she wasn't passionate about and she
might be struggling with finding her
passion and so I have this article from
the Atlantic it's called find your
passion is awful advice which is very
suspiciously similarly titled to an
essay that I wrote five years ago dude
there is it's a compliment yes it's a
very good comment and but it's actually
well my guess is the author actually
didn't did not generally with with
articles like in and organs like the
Atlantic that author does not get to
pick their own title oh I gotcha fee
there's some editor somewhere the pics a
title yeah anyway we did an interview
with Cal Newport it was called follow
your passion is shitty advice right well
put a link that in the show notes but
also I'll put a link to this I just
wanted to to read the beginning of it to
maybe point you in the right direction
here Emma Carol Dweck a psychology
professor at Stanford University
remembers asking an undergraduate
seminar recently how many of you are
waiting to find your passion almost all
of them raised their hand and got dreamy
looks in their eyes she told me they
talked about it quote like a tidal wave
would sweep them over sploosh
huzzah it's a counting that's the thing
like yeah I mean very rarely as
someone's I found my passion it's
accounting right yeah
although we've talked about Colin or our
accountant he seems to be really
passionate about mounting wood they have
unlimited motivation for their passion
they nodded solemnly I hate to burst
your balloon and she said it doesn't
usually happen that way the article goes
on to decide a bunch of studies and
references I'm gonna well have Sean put
a link to in the show notes but let's
talk about scrape man well yeah it's
like the reason why everyone's nodding
their head like yes I'm always gonna be
motivated it's because we do have this
saying in Western society about how if
you find something you love to do you
never have to work a day in your life
and there's somebody out there who's
probably like yeah that's my life and I
get up and I don't feel like I ever have
to go to work and I love what I do but
that is a vet Jordans over there raising
his hand you know and and and but Jordan
is an exception to the rule right like
that is not that is not the rule it
going back to the expectations that we
set for ourselves like that expectation
can really be detrimental to us it's
it's not it it's it is uh it's not good
to have that expectation and I'm arguing
that having that expectation is actually
really really harmful to someone it is
because it presupposes that you were
born to be a nurse or an astronaut or an
accountant or whatever it may be there
is not one thing that is going to be
passionate and by the way the thing that
you're if you do find something that you
can cultivate into a passion you may not
be passionate about it for the rest of
your life yeah absent if it might change
all together for me fiction writing was
was the the prime example I I'm still
really passionate about writing but I
always thought like that's what I would
do for the rest of my life and I left
the corporate world like fiction writing
was the thing and then now that's what I
wanted to do and I haven't in earnest
written any published any fiction since
2012 yeah and I haven't written a whole
lot that's publishable since then I
couldn't I couldn't honestly say well
I'm a fiction writer because I don't
even write fiction right I and it's not
the thing I'm curious about anymore it
is a thing I was really curious about in
my 20s and I followed that curiosity but
guess what that curiosity led me down a
different path to another curiosity but
if I were to have found my passion then
it'd be something I could never leave I
couldn't
doing this right now I couldn't be
helping people solve their problems via
a different medium whether it's
podcasting or riding on a blog or making
our next documentary I couldn't do that
if I was so fixed on I've already found
my passion you know or something worse
might happen to when we have that
expectation we find something that we
really like we really enjoyed doing like
writing for example and then all of a
sudden you get to a point where you're
like man this feels like work oh I must
not really be passionate about it I mean
so having that expectation of I find
something I love I get up I don't work a
day in your life and then you find
something you like and then you realize
like oh wow this is a little bit of work
I could you know make someone just shrug
off that time and the energy that that
they wanted to put into that passion but
you know just realizing that yes you are
going to have to work like you were
going to do - you and I there's not
anything else I'd rather be doing like
what we're doing is is amazing and I
wake up every day grateful for it and I
still feel like there are days where
like we work our asses off well it
reminds me we did a patreon livestream
we do a monthly patreon livestream for
the patrons and one of the questions on
the last one was about if you had a year
left to live what would you do with that
year what what would you different do
differently and it's actually a question
I've asked myself since 2011 yeah um
it's a yeah and I wouldn't do anything
differently because I'm already living
my life how I would live it if I just
had the rest of this year left to live
yeah now where I may be adjusts in
particular and move some stuff up around
yes but the end result of the year would
be would be the same and you and I had
this conversation like what the hell
happened in 2006 and and it was like I
don't really remember what happened in
2000 was that the year that the
promotion or was that - I don't remember
and you were like well there was alcohol
and drugs involved but I that wasn't
just 2006 and and like the point is like
now ever since making this decision
living living life one year at a time
because I don't have some grandiose
10-year plan like well here's where I'm
gonna be ten years from now no I know
what we are going to focus on for the
next year because you and I talked about
we have
conversations we're gonna grow together
this way and we adjust accordingly but
we know we're gonna do them but we can
also look back and say hey remember in
2010 when we started the website you
member in 2011 we published our first
book to you number 2012 during the
holiday happiness tour do you remember
2013 when we moved to Missoula and
started a publishing company number 2014
when we did the hundred city tour do you
enver in 2015 we did the word tasting
tour and finished filming the
documentary do myrrh in 2016 we released
our documentary remember in 2017 we
started yeah and you have all of these
different each year we have this thing
that we can look back on and say all our
resources our time our attention our
money our skills yeah yeah it was all
focused on on this major project
everything else sort of focused on that
and so we're doing something meaningful
because we did focus on it and and I
think that's where where Emma has to be
right now is how is she going to use
those resources don't don't wait around
to find your passion it's find your
curiosity what are you interested in
right now and then and then move in that
direction we really need to come up with
a new sit leg I want to rephrase the if
you find something you love to do you
never work a day in your life let's try
and rephrase that right now so maybe the
saying should be find something that you
don't mind working towards there's
something there man there's another
saying that we have to start putting out
into the world yeah that just sets the
red expectation of of cultivating a
passions hard work right right yeah
finding something that finds something
that is worth working your ass off for
yeah like that yeah that's good we can
work toward something pithy er yeah here
you pick pick the best pithy the best
pithy tweet their podcast Sean and put
that out there and add four end dashes
to it all right so I think that's oh I
do want to give him a book because I
think our book everything that remains
will help arouse it it's my favorite
thing that we've ever written it's
twelve different chapters about Ryan's
and my journey from being the deflating
balloon sort of successful in the
corporal
world but then also walking away from
something that there was no longer
meaningful to us but not just walking
away but walking toward a more
meaningful life and so the recipe that
we went through and it's two sessions
it's the everything session and in the
remains section getting past the
everything part and that that started
with the stuff and then also the
relationships and and the corporate
world and the the the wrong kind of
drudgery and moving forward to the right
kind of drudgery yeah and and being
willing to spend our resources in a
better way so Sean if you reach out to
her give her the audiobook version of
everything that remains or if she wants
the book book or the e-book we're happy
to give you those as well and for
everyone else we'd love to hear what you
have to say so if you have a comment or
a tip about challenges or struggles that
you've had then we're including advice
for any of our callers today leave us
voicemail for zero six two one nine
seven eight three nine you can also
email a voice memo to podcast at the
minimalists comm what are our favorite
comments and tips on a future episode
and stay tuned to the end of this
episode for this week's listener
comments and tips Ryan what time is it
it's time for our lightning round you're
supposed to act like you're getting
shocked right now yeah if you're not
watching this on YouTube then Ryan is
doing something with his hands is he
he's petting some large animal that's
trying to get away from him I can't wait
to see what Jordan does with that he's
been too much time on his nonsense he's
gonna put two dogs right alright yeah
the lightning round now we're on Twitter
Facebook and Instagram at the
minimalists during the lightning round
that's where Ryan IH do our best to
answer every question with just a short
shareable less than 140 character
response we'll also put the text to
these minimal Maxim's in the show notes
so you can copy and share our pithy
answers on social media if you'd like
and now you can find all of our quotes
in one place thanks to our good friend
Jessica Lynn Williams over a minimal
maxims comm you know she relaunched her
podcast this week nice she handles all
of our social media it's called tada
so she's do a podcast with her friend
Melissa on the other side of the pond
called the mind Palace and she is she's
doing her on her own now and she's
interviewing different people every week
and it's called tada so you could find
that wherever you listen to podcast
where's our first lightning around
question from Ryan our first lightning
round question is from Chris Chris
writes in is procrastination always a
bad thing sometimes I need to walk away
from a project before returning to it
with a fresh perspective I totally get
this man yeah I get it to it here's my
first pithy answer I have two for Chris
and then we can talk about it Ryan don't
let your amateur crass donation turn pro
boom yeah I think we can be we can
procrastinate but then what happens with
me sometimes if I put something off a
little bit I'm like I'm already gone
down the rabbit hole I might as well
just say forget everything I put it off
for a day I'll just put it off for a
week yeah yeah yeah and then it
perpetuates until a I continue to put it
off and you feel bad about and you
realize that and once you finally get to
it two three months down the road and it
took him an hour to finish this project
you're like wait a minute I've been
worrying about this I've had the
psychological clutter for the last three
months
because I didn't I wasn't willing to
spend an hour getting this out of the
way yeah and so yeah I think about that
the second short answer the second
minimal maximum I have for you Chris is
a planned respite isn't procrastination
any more than a than a planned car crash
is an accident and if you plan to crash
into a wall that's not an accident you
did it on purpose right and if you plan
to take a little break for so that's
necessary it's the interval training
that we just talked about right yeah
absolutely my short answer is this one
can differentiate taking a break from
procrastination by considering the
amount of guilt they feel during
downtime from me like this is key
because there are some times when I need
to take a step back from a project and
really let some things that just let
some thoughts digest but if I'm actually
taking a break I don't feel guilty about
it right when it becomes part of the
process
Frank is part of the process exactly but
then there are other times when I am
finding distractions and as I'm you know
following through with these
distractions I start to feel guilty
because I'm like oh I should have been
doing this I should have been doing that
and that is where those are the the
signifiers that I look for and in myself
to really differentiate between am I am
I actually taking a break or am I
actually ignoring this this important
task that I need to I need to work on
and so maybe maybe Ryan that the
distractions are related to
procrastination and maybe the
intentional break is related to the
project itself related to the creativity
Cal Newport talks about this and in deep
work when he talks about you know
spending time you know just like taking
a walk and in fact if you look at Mason
Curry's book where he talks about daily
rituals
whether it's David Foster Wallace or
Mozart and everyone in between the two
things that I notice in almost all of
the the people in this book I think it's
a hundred and sixty three case studies
of different creative people mostly
writers but not all of them I noticed
some sort of caffeine consumption and I
noticed daily walks oh wow and for most
of them I notice early early working as
well not for all of them though there's
some of them like Hunter s Thompson who
yeah I guess it was earlier he's writing
started at midnight it's really early
yeah the first hour of the day that's
crazy all right our next question is
from Claudine how can you be in a
relationship with a person who collects
stuff all right so so here's my pithy
answer for you and then let's talk about
it find your breaking point before you
are broken and and what I mean by that
is there's an amount of hoarding that
you're willing to tolerate but there's
also an amount of hoarding you're not
willing to taller imagine there is some
point you love Mariah I don't believe in
I don't actually don't believe in
unconditional love there's always
conditions if she tried to stab you with
a knife every morning you would stop the
relationship yeah if she'd like joined
the Ku Klux Klan
some relationship I don't think she'd
get in the Ku Klux Klan anyway I don't
think they would accept her Ryan anyway
yeah but yeah there are there are there
are conditions yes yeah and so like well
you know let's just unpack that for a
second uh-huh
so there are conditions to expressing
love like if if Mariah somehow got into
the Ku Klux Klan they let her in yeah
she found a little they didn't do the
23andme tests on her right right
then she went in with white face right
right then then I would still love her I
mean I still would like my heart like my
yeah like my heart would still like go
out to her but I could not express
support for you know her interfering
with other people's well-being so so yes
like maybe there is a such thing as
unconditional feeling of love right
right but but there are conditions to me
expressing my love towards something I
think it's a great way to put it in and
so there would be a point where if she
became a hoarder all of a sudden like
the kind of hoarders you see on TV dead
cat in the fridge yeah pizza boxes
strewn across the floor all the time
there is some point Reeb like I can't
tolerate this anymore right
I can't even tolerate it and so but yeah
I would have many conversations leading
up to that point though right exactly
and so there is a point at which you
would no longer accept the hoarding
right
now you have to figure out and I think
Claudine has to figure out what is that
point what is the breaking point for you
because if you're past that breaking
point then the relationship is probably
broken now can you fix a broken thing of
course you can fix a broken thing
doesn't mean necessarily you can't
always put all the pieces back together
right
and so where is that breaking point for
you if someone is that's really pithy by
the way you you can you can usually fix
a broken thing but maybe not put all the
pieces back together
Sean can edit that make it work yeah and
I think that's the case even if it's
someone who collects stuff like you have
to be able to accept and tolerate I mean
having a five-year-old daughter with me
like what she likes to hold on to
definitely not the the thing I would
like to hold on to now ultimately I get
the final decision but I'm not going to
impose every preference that I have on a
five-year-old no you're only a wet loud
to wear monochrome clothing raela yeah
you can have only four toys purple
dresses are stupid
oh she gets value from those things and
so I had to be willing to appreciate it
but there there is a level where I'm
like hey you need to clean up your toys
after you don't play with them they
can't be there on the living room floor
and so what is the level that is the
breaking point and let's let's avoid
that breaking point and work together up
into up into that at that point I
totally agree my short answer is this
you can be in a relationship with a
brick wall if you love and accept it
enough the question to ask is how do our
relationships align with a meaningful
life so Claudine what I'm trying to say
is this is that you can absolutely live
with a hoarder even if they have dead
cats in the freezers Claudine you have
to decide what that relationship does
for your life and if accepting the cat's
in the freezer if that means living a
more meaningful life for you Claudine
then that's great like no one's gonna
judge you for being with a person like
that but if Claudine or anyone else out
there is in a relationship where where
people are yeah they got the cat's in
the freezers and like there's what
there's an obvious problem yeah try to
fix the relationship try to try to go
out of your way to speak kindly to that
person and ask them for support but
here's the key man in order for Claudine
to get the support back she has to make
sure that she has been supportive to her
partner yeah so so that's that's really
step number one if you're looking for
someone to support you look in the
mirror and ask yourself how often have I
gone out of my way to support this
person that I'm asking for support from
because what if they get value out of
their collections if they've collected
yeah if they collect angel statuettes
maybe they get immense value from that
yeah then and the question is are you
willing to tolerate that there for me if
I can I mean I love Bex and I would
probably put up with an angel statue at
collage yeah like if it really added
value to her life you would be like you
know what that's silly but I want to
support you being happy I
to support your preferences right but
there is a point where I mean obviously
the dead cats in the freezer thing is
like that's a I mean I think Beck's is
super hot but I even I mean I couldn't
tell you know that but that doesn't mean
flooding couldn't no I'm just so what
are you I mean the question is like what
are the dead cats and there's a whole
other level of things I wouldn't
wouldn't tolerate in our relationship
thankfully I found someone who has
similar preferences to me and we've
neither one of us collect anything but
that's how you develop good
relationships man yes it's like you find
people who you have similar preferences
with do you have similar values similar
beliefs especially if you're living with
that person now my friends have
radically different preferences and and
that's okay because I don't have to live
with them I don't have to deal with
their stuff on a daily basis we're able
to have meaningful conversation left for
an atom who's moving his family is
moving this this month he sent me a
picture of like there he's got four kids
and a wife and they're actually moving
to a house is the same size but
different in terms of bedrooms and stuff
they they're they showed me a picture of
this trailer it looked all their stuff
look like a FEMA rescue trailer I mean
it wasn't all these organized bins and
stuff I'm like are you helping like a
bunch of families who have made it
through a hurricane or something but
that would drive me crazy personally but
again I his life isn't mine
right and I can have a great
relationship with him without without
and here's the thing those are actually
things that they need for their family
if I had that much stuff in my house it
would be inappropriate for my life so
maybe figuring out what is appropriate
for you is going to help you identify
the people that you can be in a
relationship with Claudine and what what
that relationship looks like all right
where do PS Ryan we have one more
question
Yemen and that question is from Bora
Bora says I want you to name three
challenges that you like facing yeah so
since we're talking about challenges
today this is the perfect question so if
you want to hear our answer to that
question you can listen to this week's
PostScript episode over at the
minimalists private podcast it's
available exclusively to our patreon
supporters so if you want to support the
show and keep this
Podcast a hundred percent advertisement
free then head on over to the
minimalists comm slash support in
addition to our weekly PostScript
episodes the minimalist private podcast
feed includes our monthly ask the
minimalists anything episodes unreleased
recordings of our live events and the
entire back catalogue of past private
episodes once you become a supporter
you'll receive a personal link to our
private podcast feed so it will play in
the normal podcast player that you're
listening to or you listen this podcast
to right now and as a patreon supporter
you also receive access to our monthly
live stream videos as well as first
access to tickets to all of our live
events before those tickets are
available to the general public you can
find all the details and all the good
stuff over at the minimalists comm slash
support and here is a snippet from this
week's PostScript episode quite often
we're going through a challenge I think
they're the same for me like we rarely
enjoy them in the moment right but we're
grateful after the fad life when you and
I we write a book or even a blog post
like it's not always fun in the moment
it can be like you get to this point
where it's like oh this is actually
coming together and it gets exciting
eventually but at the beginning you're
staring at the cursor on a blank page
yeah and that's like oh man there's so
much work ahead of me a blank page yeah
and so I think that we're grateful after
the fact because the result improves our
overall well-being
[Music]
okay now it's time for our added-value
portion of the show this is where we
each talk about something that has added
value to our lives
recently Ryan I sent you a a link to an
album I sent it to Shawn and Jordan as
well this new new band they're not next
album come out last year they're called
lovey the band it's all one word nice I
think they just want to name their band
lovely but in the age of social media
lovey was taken all the social media so
they're at lovey the band on Instagram
but these crazy to think that social
media well I guess websites like they
dictate write what you wow that's crazy
yeah so but their album it's it's
definitely my top five right now of this
year not checked out yet it's it's
called finding it hard to smile was a
plane last night at all on the know your
place know I was an aquilo playlist but
uh finding it hard to smile is the wrong
title for this album I would call it
finding it hard not to smile this album
is like I've you catch me dancing
there's something wrong but like I found
myself I just move into the album like
what is going on my body won't stop but
like it's so well written some of the
lines on here are just amazing it's a
longer album - for like a it's sort of
like a new new pop rock album but it's
maybe 16 songs mm and every single song
on the album is good it is on believe
it's it's they're from LA actually the
lead singers from New York they live in
LA and man it is it sounds like like Los
Angeles but like it's like good I don't
even how to describe it man it's just a
really great album all the way through
from the first song of the last song it
has been on repeat for the last week
week and a half for me that's all so
check it out it's called lovely the band
finding it hard to smile what's been
adding value to your life recently
well Josh you know how I love to
recommend albums that are a year old but
I just came across thriller I just
discovered
maroon 5's album red pill blues red pill
blues haha did you recommend this
already no I didn't get not any maroon 5
fan personally me either
yeah like I I don't like pop music in
general I don't go out and like seek the
newest latest pop because it's usually
singles uh-huh very rarely does a pop
artist come out with an amazing album
and they've done it dude really yeah you
should check it out you you out you you
would dig it anytime you recommend
something on this podcast I always at
least check it out it is a it is a it is
a it's a great album good lyrics and see
I do Mariah and I do you know we do
dorky dances in the kitchen when we're
making dinner or whatever do yeah and
like we've been dancing in this album
for like the last week I'll be walking
out we were walking at dodge ball the
other night and like really danced it
down the street dude it was just so good
it's so good
well Chaminade well in this episode with
the the lead single from lovely the
band's album it's called broken although
if you're watching this on youtube we'll
just put a link to the like oh there's
probably picture and picture thing you
can do with their video it's a really
good video to the song is amazing it's
called broken alright let's move on to
right here right now so we talked about
what's going on in the lives of the
minimalist the speaking of YouTube we've
got a whole bunch of YouTube stuff going
on first off if you want to leave a
comment on this episode I found it the
best place to leave a comment on a
podcast episode for us is on YouTube and
here's the thing YouTube comments
usually suck they're awful except for
whatever reason you all have been
awesome with respect to our YouTube
comments they're either their
conversational or their helpful are you
talking about the lighting or or
there was a sound issue with the last
video that we uploaded so we had to
delete it and when we found this out
because people are commenting on it and
so and we had to re-upload it and Jordan
had to spend a whole a whole Monday
going through the pain of of reuploading
a video but anyway you can leave a
comment about the episode and we make
sure that we read all those you can also
interact with other people who are
commenting it and if you have additional
comments so that you just wants us to
leave and you're scared to call it
for some reason calling in is always the
best thing too because you'll you'll
will air it at the end of this episode
but you can also comment on the episode
on YouTube on this particular episode
also on YouTube you can find the full
podcast episodes on Mondays that's a day
before the audio podcast comes out on
Tuesdays
also new pre-roll episodes on Tuesdays
sort of behind the scenes of the podcast
or show prep for the podcast you can you
can check that out every Tuesday we're
doing it live so right around close to
10:00 a.m. Pacific Time on Tuesdays you
can find live or you can find the video
once it's uploaded as well also new
living room conversation room
conversations so we were gonna change
the name of this we we put up a poll and
said alright we're thinking to change
the name because sometimes we record it
not in a living room right and someone
left like the profound comment the the
pho found comment love like man if
you're alive in a room isn't it a living
room oh man and I appreciate that so we
put up a poll on YouTube and said hey
we're thinking about changing the name
do you want to keep it the same as a
living room conversation do you want to
make a difficult convert conversations
because we do we have difficult
conversations about questions that
aren't difficult to us anymore but I
realize why they're asked these question
because they're having a difficult time
with them so difficult conversations or
the other one was like that's a great
question
because that's that's always like the
filler that we people bring up late if
we're trying to think about I need to
pause and think for three seconds about
this question oh that's a great question
thanks it it's a great name for a
podcast it is so you all are welcome to
use that if anyone but we're gonna keep
it living room conversations will
usually record it in my living room once
a week we're gonna put those up on
Wednesday starting this week and then
new quickie episode so what we're doing
Jordan I and and Jess have been working
together to isolate little snippets from
the long podcast cuz we're recording
this podcast today I don't know how long
it's been an hour and a half two hours
whatever it is and and there's gonna be
like little three minute segments or
15-minute segments or eight-minute
segments you can tweeze out here's an
example I'm
back and you know I did that three hour
and 30 minute podcast and my doctor's
about my health problems yes there's 26
quickie episodes within that podcast
Iceman so there's one where it's talking
about being a vegan but then eating meat
as as medicine or there is a episode
where we talked about our CBD THC and
nootropics from a doctor's perspective
and so instead of having listened to
full three hours on YouTube you can find
these little three or 20-minute clips
it's great and have those have those
right there for you in there there well
I like about those those are more
shareable so people will find value in
those in a different way from the
podcast we're also working on tour recap
vlog we were just on the simply southern
tour and and Jordan is working on
pulling that together I can't wait to do
that doing that is gonna be a lot of fun
doing that people actually get to see
what our what our lives look like
because I mean this question I hate dude
I hate this question so Ryan tell me
about an average day in your life what
does an average day look like to you
that it like that presupposes a that we
should have average days yeah we should
have this set day that we owe well from
night I get up at nine o'clock and I
write for an hour and then I go surfing
from 10:00 to noon and then by one
o'clock I'm back with them right yeah I
mean yeah like and I hate that question
I'm projecting this hate because I don't
have a good answer for it yeah there is
not a normal day there is talk about an
ideal day but you can't have an ideal
day every day
no but this vlog like when people start
asking me that question I'm just gonna
refer to them to look at the vlog yeah
so we're gonna do a monthly vlog called
live a meaningful life and it's talking
about you know sort of a day in the life
of the minimalist or a month in the life
of the minimalist it's the the Josh and
Ryan show we're also gonna do a
behind-the-scenes thing for Instagram TV
IG TV where it's not the Josh and Ryan
show it's going to be all the work that
goes in from different parties where
it's podcast Sean or Jordan or Jessica
or Dave or Jeff all the people you'll
get to see the inner workings of the
minimalist team and yeah it's gonna be
called behind the minimalist I love it
yeah it's kind of like behind the music
this was this was a jordan's idea that i
think you and Jordan came up with with
that side man and and so we're also
going to do some minimalism tips we're
gonna do a this will be somewhere in the
future but on YouTube we're gonna do
more
some tips we're gonna do home tours of
Ryan's in my homes we're gonna do other
YouTube shows and you can find all that
more over at our YouTube channel it's
just youtube.com slash the minimalists
and if you want our podcasts in podcast
notes in your inbox then you can all the
show notes you always hear me say hey
podcast shot put that in the show notes
you can find all that over at the
minimalists coms enter your email
address at the top we'll never send you
spam do we should though we should every
time someone signs up with their email
address
we should get their physical address and
send them a can of spam oh I was gonna
give you a health update maybe I'll do
that next week we've been going quite
long on this and I'll give you because
I've been experimenting a little bit
with what I've been eating this month
and I've introduced a few things back in
slowly and a few things have screwed me
up so we'll talk about that next week
hopefully have you checked out our side
project it's called minimalism dot
life.we well it just go to minimalism
that life I want to say check that out
what's funny is like minimalism that I
mean I know we're part of it but like
what minimalism that life is like it's
better than what the like we as the
minimalist I feel like because it's like
the minimalist SAR a piece of it yeah
but it's it's just all Tron right yeah
dude it's Voltron and it's until Carl
and Alberto and then we have a bunch of
people writing articles for it it's
mental minimalism about life you can
also follow Carl and Alberto do a great
job of curating the Instagram feed it's
just at minimalism life on Instagram
beautifully beautiful photos but also
meaningful quotes as well and it's find
that at minimalism got life Ryan you got
anything else for us today yeah man I
got all these voicemail comments and
tips from our listeners our favorite
part man check them out hey my name's
Sarah I am in San Francisco I'm actually
calling as I was listening through the
acquaintance podcast just now I'm a
stay-at-home mom with three kids so
plenty of time for that and it's just so
funny because the social media friends
thing is so relevant right now so last
week I still had Facebook and a friend
from high school that I have not hung
out with really since middle school
let's say but she went my high school
brought something that I thought was
wrong whatever
Facebook and I never responded I hate
those things but I decided to unlike it
because it was very offensive to my life
and then I was like you know what I'll
just don't follow her she doesn't even
know I'm following her anyway but I
didn't realize she saw my unlife thing
anyway I get this huge message on
Facebook about how she can't believe I'm
not her friend anymore because of this
comments cute that so I just wrote back
like hey just do you know like I'm cool
being friends I just didn't want to be
your Facebook friend so if that's cool
to you and then she was kind of like
what's there off by that we're having
this really good conversation on there
and then actually the next day I decided
you know I'm just gonna really Facebook
all together I'm kind of like I heard
Ryan discuss not having Facebook so I
don't have facebook now and it's so
freeing and it's so funny how quickly
you find out who your real friends are
this is kira previously calling from
california but now I'm calling from
Brooklyn and New York and I just wanted
to leave a tip about kind of detaching
from that it to be on your smartphone
I've been noticing myself falling back
into that pattern of just checking my
phone all the time whereas before I was
people to create a limit and just check
my phone maybe three times throughout
the day that post has an email and so I
was rereading josh is a most emergencies
aren't kind of for inspiration and
something that I have found helpful for
me if I like want to send a message
right away and then my excuse to myself
would be okay well I'm gonna forget
about this message that I need to text
it now but then I open up my messages
and then that opens a whole floodgate of
thing I have a folder in the notes
section of my phone called messages to
send so then I can write down the
message that I want to send in there and
then later if I still need to send that
message I'm actually sending it
intentionally rather than on impulse
hey this is Jenna from Salt Lake City I
was calling because I had a comment
about your latest episode the one on
parents and specifically on not getting
along our having difficulties
communicating and interacting in a way
that that you would want the
relationship to be I okay I grew up in a
fairly religious family and my mother
has always been a really good example to
me of this I've had several family
members make decisions that were
contrary to what my parents values were
and what I've seen from my mom is that
she always follows the advice that she
thought from the movie Bambi for our
this [ __ ] his mother would tell him if
he can't say something nice and he
shouldn't say anything at all and that
is my mom if she can't say something
nice about something she just won't say
anything at all but the other thing that
she does or the other things that she
does she'll find things that she agrees
with this person on and they'll talk
about that
or if they have common interests they'll
talk about that and if she can't find
something like that that's kind of a
neutral topic to discuss then she'll ask
questions about that person's interest
what are you doing right now how is your
work going how are your hobbies going
what do you do you know how skiing house
hiking house whatever you're doing she
never volunteers advice she will only
give advice and this pretty much goes
across the board with all her kids but
she'll only give advice if we
specifically asked for it she never
calls this up and says hey I've been
thinking about this problem and I think
you should do this business she never
never volunteers advice I currently am
dealing with a similar situation from a
parental perspective we adopted a child
as a teenager and their values are very
different than ours are and so there are
some things you know house we realize we
don't want them to do drugs or whatever
but basically I followed the same sort
of theme if I can't say something nice I
don't say anything at all I don't
volunteer advice on her life choices
unless she asks me
and she's 18 now so that's less and less
common but when we talk we find things
that we agree on we talk about music a
lot because we share the same seeing
likes and dislikes and music so I hope
that's helpful to you and to your colors
alright y'all that's it for this episode
if you have a question for the
minimalists give us a call for 0 6 2 & 9
7 8 3 9 you can also email a voice memo
to podcasts at the minimalists comm and
if you all leave here with just one
message we hope it's this love people
and use things because the opposite
never works thanks for listening y'all
we'll see you next time
oh yeah and check out this song from
lovely the band it's called broken and
minimus